hello everyone and welcome back to the
TCC Superfinal it's a game 14 and it's
it's quite an interesting game now Lila
with the white pieces and stockfish
decides that at some point in the game
that that stoppers will grab a pawn
now what happens from there we'll just
have to wait and see
so without further ado let's check it
out Lila with the white piece the pieces
opens with c4 sorry about that
and as usual the openings are predefined
up to a certain point but I will mention
when that is so night to have sex with
d4 and now c5 the Benoni is on the board
for those of you who enjoy playing the
Benoni
I would back-end against the Bologna
with white are definitely going to enjoy
this d5 we have e six Knight to c3 our
trade in the center and the d6 we're
Knight to f3 so just the the normal
Benoni and the g6 now and amongst humans
efore in bishop therefore are the
popular choices here the most popular
choices here however here we have Knight
d2 the so-called night to our variation
going for that
efore square a bit sooner rather than
later
efore is coming in then this night will
be riemann over to c4 from where then i
could be much much more useful disrupt
the g7 it is now as a move 7 that we are
out of book so from this point forward
both Levi in stock which are making
their own moves with e4 and now stock is
just castles will disrupt the e2 Knight
B to d7 just continuing development and
now there are over 450 games in the
database where for example castles was
played here in human games but Lila
prefers h3 here and it is as a move 10
that we have a completely new game so
let's see what happens
night that I ate a backing backing up
opening up the decibels diagonal and
also the night will keep an eye on the
d6 pawn once this night comes to c4 to
attack it
we have castles by Leah and now a6
preparing b5 of course lua prevents this
we have a 4 and rook to b8 again with
some ideas of maybe playing b5 in the
future with Knight to c4 now
a much better square for the night
keeping an eye on that d6 pawn the night
from me it nicely defends it we have
Queen to e7
and now f4 and grabbing more space in
the center and the bishop the d4 with
check with King to h2 and now Knight
beat f6 putting knife to a much better
square still having to figure out what
to do with the light square Bishop so
the d4 pawn is attacked twice Oh Bishop
to f3 legal a defense it and now comes
the moment we've discussed in the
beginning of the game here stock which
decides that stock which will now grab
upon and it comes with the price of one
dark square bishop so Bishop captures
and c3 removes the defender of the e4
pawn be captures on c3 and now Knight
captures on e4 now can stock Ridge get
away with this let's let's see what
happens Leo goes a queen to e1 rook to
e1 also possible but again will be met
with f5 s Oliva has different plans we
have Quinta a one with a double attack
on the night and of course if the knight
moves the Queen falls on e7 as it is
undefended so f5 defending the knight
and now Knight to b6 just stifling
White's development of the Queen side
the rook is now pretty silly there and
the Bishop still not clear where the
where the bishop is going and well
that's that's that's what what Lila
wants to do and stock we didn't really
have any better moves than to grab that
pawn so it's not that stuff we should
deliberately grab the pawn to get a
passive position it was already a
passive position so why not have a
passive position being up upon so night
8 to f6 by stockfish just improving the
the position of the pieces we have C for
strengthening the 5 also the Queen can
now enter the game on the Queen side
Bishop to d7 and now rook to a3 just
improving the position of the rook now
with control of the third-ranked also a
nice roof left with rook to e3 will be
possible later with h5 and now King back
to G 1 we have rook to f7 and now rook
to e3 by Leela and now completely
dominating in the e-file we have a 5 and
this a
five is a is a weird move by stockfish
but sawfish needs to get some
counterplay and if you don't do it then
white will play a five grab even more
space on the queenside completely you
know so it's a little solidified that
night on on b6 then the bishop is coming
to be to grabbing hold of this diagonal
at some point you might even bust open
with with the g4 and the black can
either wait until until all of those
things happen or try an active plan with
a 5 and this is what stockfish does so
Lila grabs the pawn Queen captures on a5
and now Queen to be a to sing ok your
knight isn't going anywhere now as if it
moves I just grab your queen
so ok Bishop to b2 by Leela and now h4
it's ok
the stock which gave back the pawn but
at least the alleles queen is now a bit
paralyzed there on the Queen side rook F
the e1 getting this rook double on the
e-file we have kink to h7 and now comes
Luke to b3
now the night is defended and now alas
Queen can once again move so quinta fate
no point in pretending the pin exists
and now comes Bishop captures on f6 you
have to capture with the night if you
capture with the routine just Bishop
characters here will win you the pawn so
Knight captures on f6 and the now comes
Queen back to d2 with Queen to g7 now by
by stockfish and now a 5 continuing to
push the pawn we have King to g8 and now
Queen to f2 attacking the h4 pawn g5
defending it and now Leela finds Knight
captures on d7 grabbing that piece we
have Knight captures on b7 and now rush
up to age 5 dislodging the rook we have
rook F the F 8 and now rook the e6 with
with threats of Luke to g6 just winning
a queen so Knight to f6 defending and
now you you cannot go for a row
characters here because then you hang
the bishop so Queen to e to little a
defense the bishop and now Queen to h6
with a double attack on the bishop here
we have Bishop to f3 and now again not
much not much for you to do a stock
which tries g4 very active now that the
bishop is once again under attack each
character sin
for f captures and Bishop characters on
g4 but now Queen captures on f4 again
with a double attack on the bishop here
Bishop to h3 and now stock which finally
gets in Queen to see one with check and
now if you go back then it's just the
Queen back to it for checking back to
the background Queen back to c1 which
chair so here Leah decides to block with
the Queen Queen e1 we have captured
stock castrates Queens and came to g7
and it seems like stock wishes out of
the woods as the position is well the
position is as it is but the material is
equal on the board however a Leila's
position is much more active and if she
does have a bishop against tonight with
play on both sides of the board so rook
the b6 another active move just going
after the d6 pawn so look F to d8
Stockbridge defends it and now rook eat
a be one with a double attack on the b7
point and there's no way to defend it
you cannot go here as the bishop covers
d7 so our stock which again has to go
for some activity rook to e8 goes after
the e5 pawn but the b7 pawn Falls with
check so rook captures and b7 with check
King to g6 and the now comes rook to a1
just preparing to put the passport
stockfish stops it but now rook the b6
offering a trade of course stock was not
interested in the trade as he's now down
upon so look to a7 and now 86
Lilla continues to push the past pawn
yes that's what you do with passed pawns
King to g5 and now comes Luke to f1 and
now it's interesting to see how Allah
how Allah will convert this or maybe she
won't we have nice to h5 and now comes
Luke the f5 with check the night was
going going to g3 we have king to g6 and
now an interesting idea
rookie 5 of course you cannot capture as
the pawn is pinned but preparing rook
check to pick up the d6 pawn finally so
Knights the f4 guarding the the checking
square here but now King back to hu we
have king to h6 and now again rook to f5
kicking the knight further back
Knight to h5 and now Bishop to g4
forcing the knight to g3
we have night the g3 and now finally
again look T five with the threat of
rook checks on e6 so King to g6 and now
Bishop to d1 getting the bishop out of
the way so rook checks doesn't come with
King g5 and then the King King it comes
with an attack on the bishop so look
back the f7
and now Bishop the c2 with check king of
six and rook the e6 check finally the d6
pawn it is is falling so King g5 and now
finally rugby captures on d6 with rook
captures rook captures and now rook to
a7 again blocking the pawn but now it's
only a matter of getting this rook away
from there and Holy Love will do this is
probably by shifting the King all the
way all the way up to the pawn and then
kicking the rook away so Bishop d3 first
you want your c4 pawn defended as you'll
see later why we have king f4 and now
rook the e6 cutting off the King so the
King is unable to reach the e-file King
back to g4 and now King g1 finally the
King starts his march king g5 with King
F two nights the h5 King to f3
we have Knight to f6 now King III we
have Knight to g4 with trick now came to
d2 we have kink to f4 but again rush of
the e2 just checking if if maybe white
black is interested in giving up the the
night here so tonight's the e5 of course
not allowing this end King to c3 now we
looked the g7 trying to grab hold of the
pawn here
Bishop the f1 now simply guarding it
rogue back to a7 and now comes King to
b3 so little pellet a little bit little
the white king is making progress with
Knight g4
King to a4 we looked at a 8 and then now
came to b5 with Knight to e5 now now you
can see that it's very useful that to
the bishop guards the the c4 pawn king
captures on c5 so now it's four points
to one of course completely winning rook
the c8 width check King to d4 again very
useful that the best regards the c4 pawn
now that it's attacked twice
Knight to d7 we have rook to e7
attacking the knight and now Knight the
c5 blocking the pawns but now a7 so we
have nice to be three with check King to
c3 and Knight back to c5 with King to be
four by Lila and Knight to e4 now but
here
Lila finds a very very tactical idea g3
with chick saying that okay if the King
captures then I win your knight if you
capture with the night then Bishop age
three attacks the rook and after the
rook moves now that the knight no longer
guards these two scores I can just start
pushing this point for example d7 rook
to e8 it's game over and of course if H
captures again it's just Bishop the g2
now with a double attack on the night
and after the knight moves against e5
you start pushing and that's pretty much
at night at 5 let's say check you you
pull the King back and now again you
just start pushing your pawns and that's
that's an easy win so King the f3 by
stockfish instead but now G captures on
h4 grabbing yet another pawn and
creating yet another passport so rook
the a8 but now even Bishop the g2 check
by Leela stockfish captures we have
captures and now rook captures on a 7
we have d6 rook the b7 check King to c5
we have rooked the f7 and now look the
e7 just offering a trade of rooks rook
the f5 check King to b6 and I believe it
was in this position that that stockfish
resigned the game or both of them agreed
that the evaluation of the position is
just too ridiculous to continue but as
I'm not completely sure if the game
ended here I will just check once more
yep the game ended here sorry about that
but yeah that's game 14 of the match and
with this match with this game over game
14 Lilla took to be the lead in the
match but you know it's still very early
it's only only 14 games well actually
more games have been played by now but
I'm only covering game 14 now so I'm
gonna spoil any future results but if
any of you wanna check out the match
live I will put a link to it in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see and you can follow
all the games live there played all the
time
their classical games so it's not those
you know one minute engine games so the
real playing classical chess here and
you can follow it on the under link
below sure that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
you guys did say that you would enjoy
more more games from this match so here
they are I would like to thank Daniel
Goldman and inclosure back to its solid
systems edv gmbh Cloud Strife
and dr. Howell dotnet for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day